How do you identify?
How do you justify a rejection of identity ism when a pillar of the neo Marxist
strategy is to demographically replaced the indigenous people of Europe,
London,
it's less than half ethnically English.
Um,
okay.
So let's take that question apart.
First of all,
it isn't self evident to me that it is specifically a neo Marxist strategy to
demographically replaced the indigenous peoples of Europe and um,
I don't think that's the strategy anyways,
even if that's the outcome because you have to distinguish between strategy and
outcome.
Um,
the strategy and principle is to bring in immigrants to balance out the
declining birth rate.
Now I'm not saying I agree with that.
I'm just saying that that's what the strategy is.
A,
and then the next part of the question is predicated on the assumption that
identitarianism is necessarily the answer to the problem of,
um,
the problem that's being identified,
which is characterized as excess immigration.
First of all,
we'd have to figure out exactly what identitarianism means because it isn't
clear.
Uh,
if it means radical right wing ethnic nationalism,
I don't think that that's going to be particularly constructive.
If it means having a sensible discussion about what the appropriate limits might
be on immigration,
uh,
and to think about that over the long run.
And also to have a serious discussion about
the degree to which say is lamb and,
and the west,
the values of Islam and the West are actually commensurate,
then that has to be,
obviously has to be done.
But,
um,
so I'm afraid that to answer that question,
I'd have to know more about exactly how these terms we're being,
we're being defined,
especially with regards to identitarianism cause it's a vague word.
And.